[Music]
hey you guys it's Sunday and we're doing
another sidetrack show yeah I'm feeling
like [ __ ] he's like I'm [ __ ] went out
to the club the other day I still
haven't really recovered yeah this is
the first time we've actually been out
we went out Friday night and sir our
friend Tom not not you big Tom we kicked
out cuz he's like a big really tall dude
yeah he opened a club last fall I think
in downtown Sanford called manikins it's
horror-themed yeah and uh oh we could
show it to him you know cuz I have that
he was on the news I can send you the oh
yeah okay so I can he could put it in
there him happy to have his business
back up and running
yeah because he was only just starting
to expand like we're shut down and stuff
like that so yeah they they let allow
them to reopen I think you can have like
50 people in one place so we actually
went downtown Sanford and it wasn't as
crowded as usual but there were a lot of
people out cuz it looked like a lot of
other bars and restaurants that kind of
opened up in a limited capacity he's
still asking us to be his business
partner - oh he's still asking about
that yeah you don't remember no I can't
hear it again is why it's so loud in
there no his wife came and said some
stuff to me I could say it online but it
was good you know he's like he's so
happy that you're here and you know he
wanted you guys you know to [ __ ] help
him and booty why he won't well we
already do some work with him first
yeah like I made the posters and like
that and like when he opened a 100 we
got a connections with bands and [ __ ]
like we gave him some decor tips yeah I
do Jim took and yeah actually we hadn't
been for a while and it looked like a
long a time and I was just like that
told Miriam I was like man you followed
all my [ __ ] advice it was really it
really does in there yeah it looked good
it's gonna look [ __ ] cool you know
they got a good crowd like I said it's
like you know even though you can only
have 50 people but it's like you know
they had some good [ __ ] dance played
some good [ __ ] music that all wasn't
just wave and goth all night it was I
wasn't sure if that area was gonna kind
of like you know accept that [ __ ] bar
but they did it's very good it's
downtown Sanford as well I mean down
Elias
yeah downtown Orlando
is different that's kind of like really
diverse and there's a lot more stuff
going on down there but downtown Sanford
is very yuppie and bro yeah you know
what I mean but they've been behaving
themselves they don't come in there
Tom's a [ __ ] big ol black dude he's
not gonna take any [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
like the nicest dude everybody's but but
you Roman but you don't know yeah if you
don't know him cuz he does look very
intimidating can fight and he's got big
sons yeah yeah yeah cuz him in his wife
run it and he's got low right yeah we're
so the place is well guarded you know
and they don't act up in there which you
know they go downtown they act up at
[ __ ] high bar oh yeah
on the golf nights bake time yeah they
do they're like you know they get thrown
out a lot or they used to it had been a
while there well since I've seen him in
there yeah they'll come up and like just
[ __ ] with people and [ __ ] with
people making fun of people oh yeah
which I you know it seems like I can't
believe people are still doing that [ __ ]
nowadays but it's like whatever
some people never grow up ain't that the
truth
but yeah so it was nice to get out and
see some people we hadn't seen for
months and months and drink a great deal
and have a good time dance to some good
[ __ ] so let's see I wanted to okay so we
recorded the next episode episode 199 we
recorded on Friday night so I didn't get
a chance to shout out some people that
had done like that a joint patreon or
sent me stuff like subsequently so I
wanted to shout him out on here and I'll
probably shut him on the next episode
too which probably will be a live stream
so look out sometime this week we'll
probably do like a test livestream maybe
I don't know like Tuesday evening or
Wednesday or something like that we'll
figure out it's mutters just so I can
see if it is gonna work out yeah well
there's a thing where you can announce
it's coming on live and [ __ ] like that
maybe we'll do a little short one yeah
just because I definitely want a dry run
like before because for episode 200 we
probably will do a live stream and I
think like I said aren't we gonna do
like Illuminati and all that guys Jordan
reptilians and all that so there's like
all those like stupid conspiracy theory
type things you know that's kind of
sounded like fun cuz that's something
that I've had on the list for like a
really long time and they're a bunch of
people are requests
and if it's a live shroom will probably
go wildly off-topic anyway so but yeah
so I definitely wanted to give a big
thank you to a our newest patron whose
name is Austin so thank you very much
and welcome also Dominic who sends us
quite a bit of movies he just sent me
this movie I think what I think we got
it on Friday right here Texas Chainsaw
Massacre steelbook edition that's the
nice one I am very good I didn't even
have this I don't even think I have this
on DVD or anything like that so this has
got like all the cool [ __ ] with all the
commentaries and all this kind of
jesters yeah I'm like super excited
about cuz I love this [ __ ] movie but
yeah so I definitely wanted to say
thanks about that what else was I gonna
so um yeah so like I said we'll probably
do I'm gonna put up another matinee
tomorrow which we've already recorded um
I don't know we really need to like
watch some more new movies I guess
although I got all sucked into Hell's
Kitchen season 18 which I didn't even
know cuz like we we had been watching it
like years and years ago and so the DVR
is still programmed to like record
anything with Gordon Ramsay on it um but
we never watched the TV or we never like
look at the recording so I kind of
forgot about it so we were like on there
last night I was like holy crap there's
a whole [ __ ] whole 15f it's like Al's
gets it on there that I haven't seen so
I started binging it last night and I
forgot how much I missed a little Gordon
screaming at everybody's face he's got a
new one coming out I want to see what
was it called
uncharted I think yeah I think that
starts today or I don't know I don't
remember when it starts but um we have
that like hooked up sip you know it
means if I may I [ __ ] love Gordon and
and this one this season of Hell's
Kitchen was like the it was the one
where at first it was like the rookies
versus the veterans like they had like
some runners up and [ __ ] like that from
the past shows that were lost they came
back and we're doing like a bunch of new
ones and it seems fun so far but um I
still wish that they would because we
were thinking about Kitchen Nightmares
so that was really like Kitchen
Nightmares but we liked the British
version better than the American version
yeah the American version is a little
for the top which is Hell's Kitchen is
too but it's like it's just kind of edit
on the American ones [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] American very generic American
would just look at fast paced fake [ __ ]
yeah and it's like they always in and
you know what angers yeah if that's what
like driving a crazy it's like and they
should know I mean nowadays everybody
knows those tricks well and nowadays to
this now everybody's DVR stuff and
binges stuff it's like you don't need to
like spend the first two minutes after
you come back from a commercial
recapping stuff because people are not
watching the commercials so it's like
you don't need to recap something that
happened like 20 seconds ago like you
know I can remember [ __ ] that far
the British ones were better they
weren't formulaic each [ __ ] episode
had its own tone depending on what the
city there were a lot longer to write
they have lessons in the UK that's why
and you see Gordon just shoot the [ __ ]
you know what I mean sometimes and you
know it was just it was just a more of a
natural feel it wasn't always like a
rage monster yeah because what I've
heard is that I mean people that have
worked with him and stuff like that
they're like a lot of that they're like
yeah he can get like pretty surety like
if you get on his bad side or whatever
but they're like most of that is like a
persona yeah you know because it gets
written because everybody loves seeing
Gordon like yelling at people yeah and
seeing how everything is shambolic and
Kali is calling everyone doolally and
all that look what he's doing is
actually very military yeah that's the
way a lot of military leadership is and
the kitchens he came out of okay we're
kind of like elite kitchens and it was a
bunch of [ __ ] egotistical dudes on
the a-game and it was constant he was
been described as he came from a kitchen
that was like made up of like the SAS of
[ __ ] yeah cooks so they just demanded
excellence and they trolled the [ __ ] out
of each other you know and you come out
hardened like that
yeah and demanding excellence which that
works and chances are the cooks probably
had some of them had military
backgrounds and that's why they
instilled that culture in that [ __ ]
kitchen yeah at the in that time you
know dicks you know but if it was easy
then you
wouldn't want to be there you're there
for the challenge yeah of the excellence
it's a basically a tough man competition
it just happens oh yeah
just happens be cooks ya ya know and it
just [ __ ] drive this [ __ ] out of each
other there definitely is a whole
culture around ya those kind of like
elite chefs every yeah but you know I've
always you know watching Gordon Ramsay
for years you know [ __ ] with a
military background of the infantry the
old school entry that I came out of I
instantly understood it I don't get I
wouldn't get you know I don't you know
and get like [ __ ] pissed off or it's
not what's good it's not personal
that's just how that is yeah you [ __ ]
up and you're gonna pay yeah he's just
trying to get and the thing about him
too is that even though he's kind of
known for like screaming at everyone but
she does do like when they [ __ ] up but
he's also like very supportive and he's
also like when you're doing something
good he tells you you doing something
good so it's not all just like abuse all
the time yeah you see [ __ ] Lee Army
in Full Metal Jacket [ __ ] yelling
it's a [ __ ] that's accurate that's yeah
and we loved it we loved it you know man
well the week didn't like it they were
gone in the first week and a half they
just they can't take it but that's part
of the test yeah they want to get rid of
anybody didn't want to be there you know
yeah it's just [ __ ] yell at you [ __ ]
you know it's [ __ ] drive you crazy
it's a crazy [ __ ] to you but you know me
but if you let it affect you than you're
weak that's that's part of the tough man
competition
yeah is to be stoic yeah and I deal with
punk with punishment the concept of some
kids don't come out of a family where
punishment was a concept so you know
they're not used to having negative
[ __ ] results for poor performance
well not in a good military or not in a
good kitchen you [ __ ] up you're gonna be
punished yeah you know that's how humans
learn yeah well the thing about it is
behavior modification doesn't work
[ __ ] in the kitchen or the military
well because it's it's a similar kind of
like yeah I mean you have to have people
working as a team everything has to be
coordinated
um you know there's a lot of like strict
safety protocols and all that other kind
of stuff it's a dangerous environment
yeah and it's [ __ ] a bunch of guys
we're
together as a team if one guy fails then
the entire [ __ ] team fails because
yeah it's five guys trying to make one
dish yeah
if the [ __ ] potatoes are wrong then
the whole [ __ ] dish and they have to
start all over I'm so yeah so everyone
you can't just tell somebody to do
something that you can't do you know
talk about your telling people or asking
people to do what you can do it was to a
high standards like Francis anything a
drill sergeant or anything a [ __ ] NCO
tells you to do he has done or can do
yeah so you never ask a subordinate do
something that you're not willing to do
or unable to do just doesn't work that
way because when you start when you have
a culture like that
the machine starts breaking down just
yes although it doesn't doesn't doesn't
apply to the [ __ ] general staff
officer I mean I know we're talking
about at a combat level inside of a
[ __ ] company these guys all have to
meet a certain fiscal requirement and
mental requirement I was the the one
woman that I laughed about the most she
was one of the veterans I can't remember
what's what season she was on initially
her name was Jen and she was actually I
was just entirely sure like why they
brought her back she was one of the
weaker cooks I think on the earlier I
think she works for like she's like a
private chef or whatever and so a lot of
times she kind of didn't know what she
was doing but I'm kind of glad they had
her on the show for a little while she's
been kicked off now but um but because
she just like the [ __ ] she would say was
just so [ __ ] funny man yeah like what
was she saying about I suppose something
something about like fake booty booty
picking no touching my stuff in your
booty pic and stuff like you know kiss
my whole entire ass you know and then
she has gotten this big fight with like
Gordon Ramsay because she said that he
had sabotaged her cuz I guess she was
doing the garnishes and like she brought
some stuff over in a pan and she accused
him of like taking that pan and like
hiding it or like sticking out of there
and then like yelling at her for not
yeah so yeah she got like this big
[ __ ] cop so he just like was just
like [ __ ] off yeah he usually does
do me a favor I love it I love it yeah
so I gotta watch the rest of that like I
said maybe maybe tonight we'll watch a
new movie and then all watch some more
of that because the next one I laughed
because you know they do the cliffhanger
things like on the next episode blah
blah and so on the next episode I was
there doing a very special episode I'm
like oh my god is someone gonna get AIDS
or die or something like that's like
back at the 80s at those [ __ ] with
those [ __ ] sitcoms they'd always have
that very special episode where somebody
died or yeah somebody was like overdose
like child molestation yeah there was
it's like really wasn't there one and of
like every single [ __ ] sitcom no
matter how silly it's like punky punky
brewster had one it's like family ties
on it they always had some kind of like
somebody was an alcoholic or yeah some
[ __ ] like remember [ __ ] Three's
Company
yeah that's what they think they had one
special one where the jack was gonna
come out as being straight I think that
was gonna be a special yeah wasn't that
old is gay but he was gonna come he had
to tell them that he was gay because
back in the 70s I guess you weren't
allowed to live with - yeah you weren't
able to room with them yeah or like my
Lord would know like yeah it wasn't like
illegal but the land blow lands like it
was a stick and they might allow it so
he had to pretend that he was gay yeah
but in case you're a kid you don't
remember totally relevant yeah we grew
up listening to [ __ ] laugh tracks on
those [ __ ] things they would try
anything funny by putting a [ __ ]
laugh track on it yeah go back in time
and watch that [ __ ] this you're just
[ __ ] totally unacceptable for [ __ ]
viewership you know watch damn it's
terrible it's pain now that [ __ ] [ __ ]
aged now it really I mean it was just
garbage yeah garbage writing and just
garbage a lot of it was I mean you know
they're still like kind of a few good
sitcoms I guess from the 70s but most of
them really did not a jerk Sanford is
some pretty good yeah my grandparents
loved that [ __ ] do you know that's based
on a British show stairs Owen son yeah
because I've seen that one too all in
the family
yeah
that was with Archie Bunker yeah yeah on
the family that was my grandma my
grandpa was just like Archie Bunker I
think that's why he like that I'm like
well the show is kind of making fun of
him but okay you wanna know sometimes it
depended on their argument it was but
yeah so between Archie meathead start
calling you meathead I don't even
remember with Israa characters real name
would it cuz II just kept saw walls ball
no no man what they did what the hell
was that news all I can remember is
meathead again yeah that was back when
Sally Struthers was cute yeah I'm
getting huge yeah that's why I'm really
fat but when she was young she was super
cute yeah yeah why I forgot all about
her yeah Sally Struthers what was that
with one of those didn't she do is
[ __ ] infomercials later on yeah yeah
you know yeah and I can't remember what
they were for though I'm losing my
memory mr. nahdi doesn't matter this is
what it's like it was some kind of
insurance or some [ __ ] like that one it
no no no no no I remember it was for
starving children one it yeah yeah yeah
yeah because I remember a lot of
comedians were like making fun that was
obvious to me back then
well that was like it I think I'm more
than one comedian might have made that
joke everybody yeah like I know it's
like maybe they should have like thought
about her down well they should have
thought of the optics of that before
they like cannibal tribe no didn't she
also do like some kind of weird
correspondent school at school or
something because yet she had that line
she's like do you want to make more
money yeah yeah yeah yeah we all do well
we're like those [ __ ] there's like
classy honest man this is old cat that
was old-school Hollywood out
California and she was a she was a
c-lister to begin with okay and when she
gained weight she had she was
recognizable but you know and she didn't
want to put her on movies or [ __ ] you
know the Maine sitcoms so what do you do
you have to be you do commercials that's
like d-list yeah you got to make my
decision she just made a bunch of
[ __ ] commercials you know [ __ ]
Struthers when she was young
yeah it's like yeah it's crazy how much
well it's just it's kind of like who the
hell else am I thinking of Kirstie Alley
hoots yeah she was so thin on shears and
then she like really ballooned out later
yeah yeah which [ __ ] that's horrifying
yeah that's someone that they I mean
they must have really not been eating
when they were young and then like they
just after after they hit 30 or 40
they're just like [ __ ] oh yeah I
don't have and that dozen doughnuts guys
see him you see him at the movies and
you know you don't really know who they
are so you just kind of imagine the way
those people really are like who would
have known that [ __ ] Princess Leia it
was [ __ ] shooting up heroin snortin
lots of [ __ ] coke and [ __ ] yeah right
you don't really think about it now but
she was [ __ ] totally into drugs yeah
you know and it's hard to believe that
[ __ ] Carrie Fisher was just [ __ ]
laid out with a needle in her arm most
of the time or drunk the restaurants and
she also had I think she was slightly
schizophrenic when she yeah she had
various mental issues she was pretty
pretty hopeful or she was yeah I think
she I think she had bipolar yeah she and
she was like very hope she wrote like
several books about it like later on and
so she was actually pretty open about it
yeah but just seeing her just seeing her
in the movies you wouldn't you would
never cross your mind that she had a
drug problem
yeah yeah it's really weird because uh
in a way it's almost kind of like a
testament to some of how good their
acting is because it's like they can
later on you find out no they showed up
on set and they were totally [ __ ] up
or they're chilling but you didn't
notice like in the movie I'm like well
they're it's a good actor right there
because man I've gone to work hungover
before and I'm sure everybody noticed so
you know more power to them alright so
you wanted you are you gonna go take it
I gotta take an old man now it's okay oh
man
take it up if you want says what did you
say some chicken korma - yeah that was
actually really delicious so that's
probably you just lay down and let that
digest man all right so I'll talk to you
guys again
[Music]